hello everybody hope that you are good
I'm going to try to keep this video nice
and short because I my ideas are pretty
clear at the moment so I don't think
there is any need for me to keep talking
I also wanted to ask you guys if you
think that the audio from yesterday's
video and today's video is better than
the audio from the videos that I used
toload some months ago CU I got a new
microphone so let me know if that's
working CU I remember that um when I was
on holiday H some months ago and I put
some videos you could even hear the
frogs outside it was crazy but I hope
you cannot hear PS or something now
anyway let's stick to the Chart guys uh
yesterday we talk about something very
uh simple and it was the idea that for
me to Long Bitcoin I would need Bitcoin
to recover the daily 50 ma yesterday
price was pretty low was around here and
we were talking about the idea of
recovering we filling this week over
here that okay in this week we fill that
week we saw the bounce in the 4our time
frame this look like a w pattern okay
but then it failed once it got rejected
from the 4 or 50 Ma I'm noticing right
now but mainly from the daily 50ma okay
so yeah it looked like maybe we could
have jumped into a long within a few
hours but really the entry never got
there because we we we were waiting for
a daily candle close close above the
daily 50a and that didn't happen you can
see that rejection over there and that
pushed us back down uh let me remove
this now that drop after the rejection
in the 8 hours time frame has created a
new week we fill this week yesterday you
can see there that uh when the indicator
is set in a way that when we fill uh a
week the opacity changes okay we can
even change that more but you can see
that this week from yesterday the the
color is is fading away that's because
it's been filled and it's detecting a
new week why well basically because we
went qu a lot lower beyond the other
week in fact we've gone $500 lower so
yes that's a new week and this week is
valid to get filled all right this week
is valid to get filled so we go
ourselves a little problem that is this
week this week is likely to get filled
at least the 50% of it you guys know
that maybe we can get a reaction at the
50% if not that was the case of
yesterday then we can drop lower towards
the 100% all right so keep an eye into
these
levels the 50% of the week is at
65,00 and the 100% of the week is at
64,500 so um anytime today it's likely
that we get there that's uh what I think
okay now from there things can get
interesting but my main concern is
that Bitcoin doesn't continue dropping
lower to retrace this liquidity pool
that goes all the way to 61,500 because
that is qu a B drop this is maybe like a
6 7% drop okay there you go 6% dropped
and that will be quite painful so that's
my main concern that Bitcoin doesn't go
there now let's check the trend for
hours time frame guys sorry if I'm
talking too
quickly um but I just want to to keep
going so you don't get bored and maybe
I'm going to try to keep videos below 10
minutes or around 10 minutes and not
longer so um you can watch the videos
quickly and then you can jump into your
charts without wasting much time now in
the 4 hours time frame you can see that
we have a trend and it's basically the
4our 50a
also makes us drop lower now if we
inverted the chart
okay you can see that this
chart is
looking pretty bullish okay let me put
that in the
again it's looking pretty bullish
because we keep
making higher highs and higher lows okay
and also the four or 50 ma is coming
along and that means that it's possible
that we go towards this liquidity pool
okay again remember this is an inverted
chart really looks like this all right
so careful with that don't H discard the
possibility of going again towards this
area below okay because that's very
possible now the only thing that uh
tells you that okay this might there
might be a little reversal here is that
if we get this level here that low you
guys can tell now
that we've just swept to slows okay look
that it just swept to slows so perhaps
let me re invert the chart again perhaps
the whole idea
was to sweep this level okay maybe test
it
again and then reverse that's the
possibility all right and it will look
like
this and complex guys well for not
really this is the way I trade okay I'm
going to tell you my plan my plan is
simply to wait for the
reaction at this level here okay because
I do think that it's very likely that
we get back here simply because the
foral time frame it tells me okay we
swept that level and it's possible that
we retest it so if that's the case then
we should get pretty close to that level
and also in the 8 hours time frame guys
remember that we have this week there
right so yes it's very possible that we
get to the area
again now once we get to that level
that's when we have to pay attention
Okay because if we start to see some
kind of bottom formation and that would
be basically I want to fill that week
without creating a new week without
creating a liquidity pool I ask one
price to go slowly back up or
consolidating you could even see some
Wicks to the downside but price not
lower not dropping lower and then that
could be another reversal pattern so
basically all that I'm waiting is to see
if we can get a reversal pattern in this
area
here or if in another hand we're going
to drop below this level let me remove
this because the chart is getting quite
messy excuse me or if we start to drop
below this level
here or even consolidate lower and if
that's the case that's telling me Ro are
dropping low okay and that's when maybe
I can open a shorter scalp but right now
that's not my idea my idea I to wait to
see what happens in this level I'll
update you through Twitter like always
um so stay tuned also to Twitter but
that is basically what I think of
Bitcoin you have then the liquidity pool
in the daily time frame which is
dangerous and also in the 4our time
frame you have this level that we've
just swept and it could be forming a
reversal pattern we don't have any proof
of that yet for that we need first to
fill the week in the 8 hours time frame
right so for now it's a game of patience
okay I'm just waiting for us to fill
this week see what happens in this one
here if you start to see weeks to the
downside but price not progressing any
further then that is telling me that the
market maker is opening Longs is
building Longs for a reversal pattern
okay otherwise if instead for example we
lose this level and we consolidate right
below
it it needs to be only like literally
two or three candles that tell me we
drop L pretty simple okay so uh that's
that's my triggers this week it seems
quite slow week um I was hoping that
perhaps yesterday last night we could
get that acceptance above the daily 50
ma to open along didn't happen we got
rejection back to square one as I said
on X and for right now just just waiting
okay just be patient and don't make any
big mistakes so that's pretty much
everything guys that I want to say but
tomorrow is Bank Hol in the US so I'm
not expecting much volatility tomorrow
and tomorrow we're going to talk about
um a bit about the Bitcoin dominance
we're going to talk about the altcoin
market and also about um maybe an
opportunity
um to make some money okay or at least
I'll tell you what I'm what I plan to do
so that's pretty much everything guys
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon